i'm pissed off i am i'm just pissed off
i'm hungry i've gained two pounds in the
last three days even though i feel like
i'm starving not over here like actually
starving but like i've just been eating
like three perfect meals a day of just
like vegetables a little fruit on the
side and a little protein and like no
snacking and i've gained two pounds and
i'm so angry i'm gonna go eat so much
pasta and i'm gonna watch halloween
movies i'm gonna watch slashers michael
myers [ __ ] i'm coming for you in the
next room in a second i'm gonna take a
shower i'm gonna get my pasta i'm gonna
live
my best i think it's time that we
normalize weight fluctuations because
that's what they are normal as a
registered dietitian i know that it's
totally normal to fluctuate two to five
pounds daily just based on water
consumption what you ate bathroom habits
that time of the month clothing etc so
if you're on a weight loss journey and
you suddenly see a two-pound jump it's
not necessarily a indicator of a plateau
or a regression plus weight loss
journeys are never linear so it's really
counterproductive to be weighing
yourself every single day plus research
suggests that frequent self-wing can
impact our mood and self-esteem
especially for folks who struggled with
disordered eating so if your obsessive
daily weighing is triggering this kind
of like [ __ ] it i might as well eat all
the things moment then it might be time
to reevaluate your relationship with the
scale remember the scale is just one of
many tools in our toolbox and of course
yes it can be a powerful motivation for
a lot of folks when the number is what
you want to see but when it's not it can
be really hard not to be dragged down so
instead i suggest focusing on
health-promoting behaviors which we can
directly control rather than the number
on the scale which we actually have very
little control over and to look for
non-weight related health improvements
like better sleep mood digestion energy
levels strength endurance etc follow for
no bs nutrition advice